pineapple jalapeno was my idea this is
all my drink that's why it's my face all
over it Flaming Joe let me get in this
bastard get in there son in this video
we're testing out three of Joe Rogan's
most popular business ventures outside
of podcasting starting off with the
Flaming Joe and ending with Rogan's
biggest and most impressive business of
all we came up with this idea we were
talking and we were talking about coming
up with a specific flavor and I said you
know what would be dope pineapple
jalapeno and he was like oh I like it
and so we went through like I think like
seven or eight different versions of it
until we came to this one but this one
just Nails it does it have honey in
anything
I don't believe so
I love honey dude seven to eight
different test batches to make this
final product means it should be pretty
good the can design is sick it's limited
edition there's UFOs all over it Rogan's
face is on it the back of the can says
experience is one of a kind spicy
pineapple flavor straight out of the
mind of Joe Rogan so awesome can I do
have to say though the name Flaming Joe
that's kind of suss all right one sip
I'm gonna give it a Dave Portnoy Pizza
score the Flaming Joe
it's a lot better than I thought the
pineapple on this is really all you can
taste I was expecting the jalapeno to be
kind of nasty but this is really really
really smooth I'm gonna give it
8.2 low carbonation no sugar kill Cliff
coffee the Flaming Joe 8.2 these are the
[__] man I love this up next is the
signature Joe Rogan senior lechuga hot
sauce there's three hot sauces that we
developed if you like hot [__] I Like It
Hot this stuff is like legit so one of
them is heirloom tomatoes winter
Truffles and Reapers and then the other
one is I don't even know how to say that
word Chula kale how do you say that I'm
not
gonna I'm in Texas I'll embarrass myself
you get your cursor off that please
Kalima salt and ghost pepper that's the
that one's rough I love them all um but
I like really hot well like if you can't
if you're like boy this Tabasco is rough
stay the [__] away from that stuff
because the stuff I like is pretty rough
first up is the hottest of the three
sauces I have no idea how to pronounce
this but we're gonna test all three of
them starting off with the spiciest one
first Joe Rogan hot sauce take one
[Music]
okay that's really spicy it's getting
hotter as it goes on let's see if the
kill Cliff kills us at all
now we're testing products with each
other
I'm gonna give the taste like a 7.2
but Joe is right about the spice I
should have stayed away that's hard
it's now time to move on to our final
product perhaps Joe Rogan's greatest
creation of all [__] my mouth's on fire
the premier stand-up comedy venue on all
of planet Earth comedy Mothership this
club has already been providing endless
opportunities in the comedy World from
established vets who need a safe place
to work out their material to new
up-and-comers who get to perform here
every single night in front of people
from all over the world there's honestly
no way to fully explain the impact that
this club will have on the culture of
stand-up and the development of
comedians over the next few decades
truly cementing Joe Rogan's place as a
living comedy Legend I mean just like
the organization of the place is great
for comedy because there's this like
centralized green room and then you can
access every all both of the rooms
without going through any of the kind of
public areas I mean that's I would
expect it to be amazing when you got a
comedian yeah yeah no it's incredible
and just like the way that he's
organizing the whole thing and how like
comic forward it is like obviously you
expect affect that from Joe but it's
different when somebody has been like
you know promoting Comedians and on his
podcasts and all his other platforms
it's different when you start a comedy
club because you go all right well this
is a business and we got to make the
business run yeah but his whole [__] is
like if it breaks even that's great so
he's just putting all the money back in
comics hands he's like he tells the
staff that works there if they're coming
with their Comics they can check out to
go do a spot wow like and then come
check back in like I mean he's paying up
Comics crazy he won't let me tell people
how much but it's crazy and now a quick
word from today's sponsor my bookie as a
better you demand Perfection and my
bookie delivers NFL and college football
season is finally upon us and my bookies
brand new cash out system gives you
options to bet and win all season long
join the my bookie family for an entire
season of free bets odd boosts and super
contests they're one of the most relied
upon Platforms in the game and have been
in business for over a decade this
season my bookie has a no strings
attached cash bonus that lets you
deposit and withdraw quickly use promo
code JK World on deposits of 50 or more
and you can receive up to 200 bucks in
cash instantly to use on your my bookie
account bet your deposit amount once and
you're ready to cash out anytime that's
promo code jkwrld to claim your cash
deposit bonus you can bet on anything
anytime anywhere only with my bookie now
back to the video that's good who's
gonna be attracted to this club is the
guys that are the the big guys that are
doing these Arenas are going to need a
place to come and work out and settle in
and do a week or two and you know uh
and we're already seeing that happen so
uh it's just the I it's just the best
thing and you never know who's gonna pop
in right you know what I'm saying the
David look at the friends last week uh
Pete Davidson popped in and you know but
he's whatever but he was just a name and
then Shane Gillis was a killer he came
by so that was some dope Poppins that
just showed up what he's doing out there
is is remarkable you know he's in in a
lot of it you know has to do with my mom
yeah you know it has to do with uh you
know how she ran it and that's why I
love being there I love physically being
at his Club because I feel my mom my
mom's Focus there and people ask me
about the club they're like what's up
with the club I'm like there's just a
focus there it was like it was when my
mom was running the club I said that to
him too you know I did his podcast a
couple of weeks ago and I said and I
dropped in on this club not since the uh
mid 70s late 70s and early 80s have I
felt that kind of excitement around a
comedy club a very that there's four
shows a night which are lined up around
the corner and they're so excited and so
electric to see you know anybody just to
the joy of the art form of comedy and
not since the comedy store has there
been a place where
it's just a must-see kind of place for
comedy yeah it's definitely I don't want
to say a tourist trap but it's a very
it's a tourist it's kind of like going
to see you know I don't know the Chinese
wax museum but in Austin you know it's a
place that Joe is built and uh they're
they're you know it's just everyone
wants to go like you said it's lined up
and um I really like being there with
him and I like being there with Tony and
I like that they named you know the bar
downstairs after my mom right and when
I'm in the bar I feel like my mom and
I'm there with Joe and we're like all we
do is talk about those days and we all
get emotional and we know we all miss my
mom because she wasn't just my mom she
was all your guys moms I mean it's
probably different for him too though
because his clientele like I mean you
got to think Rogan has been I mean
number one he's a comedian but then
number two think about all the cashier
he's built in the comedy community by
launching so many careers via his
podcast so everybody in there
everybody's pulling up of course like
it's like the least we could do is go
out there and you know spread the word
about the club not like he needs it but
I mean it works I mean I guess because I
follow so many comedians I know the name
of it comedy mothers there we go you
know and bro it's like impossible to get
tickets for it the show's been sold out
really and it's just like it's just
crazy to see a scene really get built
out of I mean it's not like they didn't
have a little bit of a scene but they
didn't have it like this
at joke world
and the world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out